Дуже багато людей приїжджає сюди,
щоб зрозуміти що їм хочеться.
Тут є час подумати.
Оця от територія,
яка відноситься до моєї власності,
починається отам, від отого болота,
від тих кущів, і закінчується коло лісу.
Тобто вся оця велика галявина, це 2 гектари.
Ті 2 гектари, які кожна людина має
отримати від держави безкоштовно.
Я досить багатьом друзям намагався пояснити,
розказати, що це можна повторити.
Це дуже непросто,
десь півтора року треба цим займатися.
Особисте селянське господарство
не стосується лише фермерства.
Не обов’язково займатися землеробством.
Це може бути вирощування лікарських рослин.
Це може бути розведення якихось рідкісних комах.
Це може бути взагалі що завгодно.
Все залежить від того, як ви на це дивитесь.
І як ви про це розповідаєте,
з точки зору різних формальностей.
Особливість цієї території, з точки зору еколога,
її дуже великий плюс, в тому,
що тут пересікаються різні кліматичні
та рослинні території.
Тобто, тут поруч є і болото, і хвойний ліс,
і акацієвий ліс, і луг, і пагорби.
І це дуже класно,
якщо ти хочеш щось робити цікаве.
Є один товариш, який приїжджає
сюди в гості з Швейцарії.
І ми з ним зараз працюємо ще тільки над проектом,
щоб створити тут місце
саме для збереження біорізноманіття.
Такі осередки вже є закордоном,
а в Україні ще немає.
Можливо, через рік, через два,
можна буде щось організувати саме на цій території.
Для того, щоб примножувати
кількість рослинок таких, які тут вже є.
Або збільшувати кількість різних комах,
які дуже важливі.
Мені здається, що всі в душі екологи,
але вони ще про це не знають.
Якщо говорити про практичну екологію,
то в мене все почалося з будівництва.
Я працював будівельником.
Я шукав варіанти як зробити так,
щоб це було більш екологічно.
Тому що на звичайному будівництві дуже мало
такого відбувається,
що можна називати корисним або екологічним.
Тут в мене буде пічка для обпалення кераміки.
Вона буде велика.
Туди можна буде загрузити багато різних виробів.
Можна буде запрошувати друзів-керамістів у гості.
Є люди, які приїжджають сюди просто на вихідні.
Є ті, які беруть участь
в будь яких роботах, в принципі.
Загалом, приблизно, до 40 людей таких активних.
І десь до 100 таких,
які підтримують іноді або грошима,
або раз на два роки приїдуть в гості щось поробити.
Можна, навіть, сказати з різних країн.
Так, якщо всі перелічувати,
то це буде досить багато.
На цій території видно кілочки в деяких місцях.
Це розмічені межі лабіринту,
який ми тут робили.
Робили його з волонтерами.
Десь... Загалом, його робили,
мабуть, приблизно півроку.
Частково його висаджували деревами.
А частково — кущами.
Основна ідея полягає в тому,
що людина заблукати в ньому не може.
Але вона коли в ньому гуляє,
вона думає про щось важливе для неї.
Думати про важливе краще, коли ти ситий.
Тому тут висаджено дуже багато ягід.
Ми зараз знаходимося в ось цій точці.
А потрапити маємо сюди.
Ну і коли ми ці всі кола проходимо...
Коло, приблизно, півкілометра
в одному та іншому напрямку.
Це такий об’єкт, на якому вдалося
об’єднати город і якусь цікаву ідею.
Це просто була піраміда.
Там де у нас акумулятори зверху треба було зберігати.
Це просто для того,
щоб заряджати мобільні телефони і ще щось.
Але було прикольно, коли ми розповідали,
що можна зарядити телефон в піраміді.
Люди думали, що воно
заряджається за рахунок форми.
Їде мій друг, місцевий.
Авторитет.
Микола Петрович.
Він приїжджає до мене за водою.
Оскільки мене вибрали,
то я як командир місцевого гарнізону.
Ми як познайомилися з Андрієм?
Я провів з ним паспортний режим,
щоб перевірити що то за людина нова.
В 2012 році у нас в Києві був клуб прикладної екології.
У нас там проводилось викладання
із бджільництва, гончарства.
В такому красивому офісному приміщенні.
І кожен раз коли це відбувалося,
то ми відчували себе якось не дуже впевнено.
Останній раз, коли до нас приїхав пасічник,
він привіз вулик пустий.
Каже: «Отут в мене живуть бджоли».
Це було так якось, не нормально.
І ми зрозуміли, що треба про ці речі
розповідати там, де є справжні бджоли.
Десь на землі.
І почали шукати для цього ділянку.
Ми звернулися в державну адміністрацію в Кагарлику.
Нам дві ділянки різних показали,
і ця нам сподобалася найбільше.
І нам дозволили тут проводити фестивалі,
навчальні табори і такі різні заходи.
І через кілька років нам вдалося
цю ділянку оформити уже у власність.
Це минулого року знову тут почався другий крок, наче.
Бо два роки була тиша.
Оцю глиняну хатку будували волонтери.
Вони вчилися ліпити з глини.
У цьому наметі живе пасічниця, яка приїжджає.
Тобто, це територія на якій працює багато людей.
І кожен, в принципі, може займатися своєю справою.
Але в більшості випадків всі один одному допомагають.
Вуликів з’являється все більше.
І є деякі вулики, які люди просто купують
і віддають їх в користування.
Якщо є можливість вона
[пасічниця] пригощає медом.
І так само з городом: люди можуть
приїжджати на город працювати,
можуть там полоти щось, чи висаджувати
і можуть потім не з’являтися.
А тоді коли з’являється врожай хтось їде на Київ
і може перевозити волонтерам щось,
дарувати щось з городу чи пригощати чимось.
Це [англійською] «перехідний період» здається називається.
Ця форма в світі існує.
Вона дуже поширена і,
особливо, в розвинених країнах.
Так воно склалося.
Просто це основа, мені здається.
Екологія, на мою думку, це єдина наука,
яка поєднує взагалі всі науки.
Це наука про взаємозв’язок
між усіма предметами, які нас оточують.
Тому без цього не можливо.
І зараз можна сказати, що це основа
не тільки для того, щоб розвиватися,
а це зараз стало основою для виживання.
Тобто, якщо раніше ми про екологію
думали як про щось таке другорядне,
то тепер нам це просто необхідно,
щоб просто як вид залишитися на планеті.
А мені на цій планеті подобається,
тому я хотів би залишитися.